Fundada en 1949 como un país socialista de
línea dura, la República Popular de China
ha cambiado mucho desde entonces. Tanto que
si el mismísimo Mao levantara la cabeza…
probablemente se volvería a caer del susto.
Amigos, si en los años 70, China no era más
que un país de agricultores muy, pero que
muy pobres, hoy es toda una superpotencia.
Ningún país en la historia ha crecido tan
rápido, ni ha sacado a tantas personas de
la pobreza, como ha hecho China en los últimos
40 años.
Durante este tiempo este país ha crecido
a un ritmo promedio de casi el 10% anual…
y lo más importante de todo, casi 800 millones
de personas - más que toda la población
de América Latina, España y Portugal - han
escapado de la pobreza.
Pero… amigos, creo que esto no es nuevo
ni para vosotros, ni para nadie. Es algo que
de una forma u otra, todos conocemos.
Ahora bien,
¿Cómo logró China semejante cambio? ¿Pensais
que toda esta transformación ha sido el resultado
de un plan minuciosamente trazado?¿De una
estrategia cuidadosamente diseñada y planificada
por los líderes chinos?
Pues, amigos, creo que en toda esta historia
hay algo que os va a sorprender. Atentos.
[Por cierto, queremos agradeceros el gran
apoyo que nos estáis brindando en Patreon.
En apenas unos días habéis sido más de
500 los que os habéis sumado a esta iniciativa.
Estamos preparando muchas sorpresas y con
vuestra ayuda será mucho más fácil]
El día 1 de Octubre de 1949, Mao Zedong,
proclamó desde la plaza de Tiananmen en Pekín,
la República Popular de China. Y lo hizo
expresando una consigna muy clara, “China
se ha puesto en pie”.
Sin embargo, durante las siguientes 3 décadas
la realidad fue muy diferente.
Mao fue algo así como un obseso de la ideología,
un personaje dispuesto a implantar el modelo
de sociedad que él tenía en su cabeza...
a cualquier precio.
Y entre otras cosas, amigos, pensaba que Pekín
podía decidir sobre todo y determinar el
futuro de todo:
Cuánto producir, qué producir, cómo repartir
a los trabajadores, cuántas fábricas hacían
falta, cómo se repartirían los bienes - la
producción - etcétera, etcétera.
Y, no solo eso. La otra cosa que Mao tenía
muy pero que muy clara… era que cualquier
disidencia era un peligro que había que eliminar.
Y, claro… como os podéis imaginar las ideas…
en manos de alguien con tanto poder y tanta
obstinación… tienen consecuencias…
(Algunos estudios, atentos, calculan que durante
los casi 30 años que Mao fue el gran lider
supremo de China, entre 50 y 70 millones de
personas perdieron la vida como consecuencia
de las hambrunas, las persecuciones políticas
y la más absoluta miseria.)
[Entre 50 y 70 millones de personas, ¡Qué
salvajada! Si quereis en un próximo vídeo
podemos hablar de todas las “grandes ideas”
de Mao.]
Bueno, el caso es que tras 30 años en el
poder; tras colectivizar toda la tierra y
todas las propiedades de China; y de perseguir
brutalmente con “la revolución cultural”
a millones y millones de intelectuales, académicos,
profesores y a cualquier persona que no fuera
cómoda para el régimen…
China era un país sumido en la más absoluta
miseria.
(“Los primeros años de la Revolución Cultural
no sólo fueron un caos, fueron un caos salvaje"
Frank Dikotter, historiador de la Universidad
de Hong Kong)
En aquel momento, más del 80% de los chinos
vivían en unas condiciones miserables; las
hambrunas no eran extrañas, el terror político
- las purgas - estaba a la orden del día
y el nivel de vida, amigos, era comparable…
al de alguno de los países del África subsahariana.
Y todo ello mientras Japón y los dragones
asiáticos, Hong Kong, Taiwan, Corea del Sur
y Singapur ya estaban despegando. [¡Menudo
éxito!]
(Por eso no puede extrañarnos que cuando
Mao murió en 1976… el Partido Comunista
chino se dividiera en 3 facciones muy diferentes
entre sí:
los radicales, liderados por Jiang Qing  - la mismísima viuda de Mao - ;
los reformistas moderados de Hua Guofeng y los reformistas más agresivos,
liderados por Deng Xiaoping.)
Al final, tras muchos tiras y aflojas, y tras
quedar claro que China no daba más de sí,
en 1978 fueron estos últimos, los reformistas
más convencidos los que se llevaron el gato
al agua.
(EL GATO NEGRO Y EL GATO BLANCO)
¿Recordáis las preguntas que hacíamos al
principio? Pues vayamos con la primera,
¿Cómo diantres cambió el rumbo de China?
En diciembre de 1978, en el XI Congreso de
Partido Comunista chino, el reformista Deng
Xiaoping se hizo con el liderazgo del país.
Deng Xiaoping defendía que había que dejar
a un lado toda esa utopía ideológica que
tanto daño había hecho a China, y que había
que apostar decididamente por la modernización.
De hecho su frase más célebre, seguro que
la conoces, es esa que dice:
(“No importa que el gato sea blanco o negro;
mientras pueda cazar ratones, es un buen gato."
Deng Xiaoping)
Y, amigos, eso es, precisamente, lo que hizo
durante los siguientes 10 años,
… porque… si algo tenemos que decir es
que las reformas… rápidas, lo que se dice
rápidas no fueron.
Pero, puede que os estéis preguntando…
vale, vale, pero Alberto, ¿Cuáles fueron
exactamente sus prioridades?
Pues, desde el punto de vista económico podemos
clasificar las reformas en 3 grandes bloques:
la agricultura, la industria y el comercio.
El punto de partida fue el campo
[Ya hemos dicho que por aquel entonces China
era, fundamentalmente, un país de campesinos].
Pues bien, con la reforma agraria se descolectivizó
el campo y se suprimieron las comunas. que
fueron sustituidas por el modelo de explotación
familiar de toda la vida.
(Además, se implantó el “sistema de responsabilidad
familiar” por el cual muchas decisiones
como qué tipo de cultivos plantar, que inversiones
hacer, que herramientas, que aparejos comprar,
pasarón del gobierno, de los burócratas
a las propias familias.
Y no solo eso una parte de la cosecha el campesino
se la vendía al estado, pero el resto podía
ser vendida en los mercados libres a precios
completamente libres. )
Y eso, amigos, fue toda una revolución…
[Pero… una revolución de las buenas…claro]
La producción agrícola se disparó y los
precios de los alimentos cayeron mientras
las condiciones de vida de los campesinos
mejoraron un montón.
Y como los resultados fueron tan buenos…
pues en Pekín decidieron aplicar reformas
similares a la industria.
De esta forma el gobierno trasladó poco a
poco la toma de decisiones desde los ministerios
de Pekín a las propias empresas públicas.
Sí, seguían siendo públicas... pero…
digamos que empezaron a funcionar con criterios
diferentes:
(poco a poco a lo largo de los años 80, los
directivos de las empresas públicas fueron
capaces de tomar decisiones como repartir
los beneficios entre los trabajadores, pagar
primas de productividad; libertad para contratar
y despedir a sus empleados; decidir con que
proveedores trabajar, fijar precios libres,
etcétera, etcétera. )
Tiene sentido, ¿no os parece? ¿Quién mejor
que los propios responsables de las empresas
para saber qué necesitan estas para funcionar
mejor?
Pues, además, todo ello fue acompañado de
la legalización de la empresa privada…
así que de repente, las empresas públicas
pasaron a tener competencia.
Y, por otro lado estuvo, también, la reforma
comercial, por la que poco a poco, China fue
permitiendo el comercio exterior desmontando
en buena medida las trabas y los aranceles
que existían a las importaciones.
Sin embargo, amigos, más allá de la agricultura,
las reformas se enfrentaron a un problema
descomunal:
China era un país muy pobre… y claro, no
tenía ni capital ni tecnología… así que….
¿Qué pensais que hizo el gobierno?
Atentos.
(LAS ZONAS ECONÓMICAS ESPECIALES)
A principios de los años 80, China era un
país pobre, cerrado al mundo y no tenía
ni dinero ni tecnología… pero lo que sí
tenía era mucha mano de obra deseosa de trabajar
en mejores condiciones que las que deparaba
el campo.
Así que dadas las circunstancias, el gobierno
de Deng Xiaoping decidió hacer un experimento:
Como no querían - todavía - renunciar completamente
al modelo económico heredado de Mao… pero
tenían que hacer algo, se les ocurrió crear
Zonas Económicas Especiales… lugares donde
el sistema comunista dejaba de funcionar.
(En estas zonas las empresas extranjeras podían
invertir y montar fábricas, es decir podían
tener acceso a la mano de obra china… Eso
de por sí podría ser una ventaja, pero…
ahí no quedaba todo. Además disfrutaban
de pocos impuestos, relativamente poca burocracia
y encima no tenían aranceles.)
Vamos, que eran algo así como pequeños oasis
para las multinacionales en medio de la entonces
hermética y hostil, República Popular de
China.
La idea de Pekín era muy clara… traer tecnología,
capital y trabajo.
Inicialmente se montaron 4 Zonas Económicas
Especiales:
las de Shenzhen, Zhuhai, Xiamen y Shantou…
y el éxito fue tan grande que pronto las
autoridades empezaron a crearlas como setas
por todo el país.
(Ahí está el caso, por ejemplo, de Shenzhen.
Cuando se creó la Zona Económica Especial
en este lugar, Shenzhen no era más que un
pueblo de pescadores pobres donde vivían
poco más de 30.000 personas.
Hoy tiene 12 millones de habitantes, próximamente
su PIB va a superar al de la mismísima Hong Kong
y es una de las capitales mundiales de
la tecnología. Todo en apenas unas pocas décadas.)
¿Conocéis empresas como Huawei, DJI o Tencent?
Pues… son precisamente de esta ciudad.
El éxito de estas zonas económicas fue tan
grande que bien podemos decir que fueron las
precursoras de la apertura china.
(“La Zona Económica Especial de Shenzhen
es un experimento. Necesitamos más tiempo
para ver si ha ido bien. Le deseamos éxito,
pero si falla, brindará lecciones importantes”.
Deng Xiaoping.)
Porque, amigos, inicialmente la idea de Deng
Xiaoping era utilizar estas zonas no para
abrir el país, sino para que el gobierno
lograra recursos con los que mantener el viejo
modelo.
Y es que se suele pensar que la gran transformación
de China fue perfectamente trazada, diseñada
y calculada por el gobierno de Pekín… sin
embargo… y creo que esto puede que os sorprenda…
no fue del todo así.
Atentos.
(LA REVOLUCIÓN MARGINALISTA)
Pensamos que las reformas chinas fueron planificadas
por el gobierno de Pekín… pero… un momento,
¿Realmente fue así?
Pues.. veréis,tras la muerte de Mao, China
era un país que estaba destrozado, la última
cruzada del llamado “gran timonel”, la
revolución cultural… había dejado al país
exhausto.
("La ironía de la Revolución Cultural es
que, hacia 1971, la mayoría de la gente,
al menos en el campo, había perdido la fe
en el comunismo" Frank Dikotter, historiador
de la Universidad de Hong Kong)
De hecho, fue durante este periodo cuando
empezaron a extenderse los mercados negros,
lugares donde al margen del sistema, la gente
trataba de sobrevivir… y eso… supuso también
un cambio cultural muy importante.
Tal vez por eso, tras la muerte de Mao…
ante el caos de la transición, algunos cambios
empezaron a producirse de forma automática.
(Por ejemplo, mientras el gobierno seguía
impulsando la agricultura colectivizada, en
algunas regiones se “rebelaron” y decidieron
poner en marcha, por su cuenta el sistema
de explotación familiar, incluso aunque esto
suponía violar las leyes y regresar, de facto,
a un sistema de explotación privada.)
Y como de repente la iniciativa sumó a más
y más adeptos, el gobierno de Pekín al final
decidió establecer estos cambios como política
estatal…
pero, realmente fue un seguidor de los cambios
que se habían producido en la sociedad.
Algo parecido ocurrió con los negocios privados
en las ciudades.
(Tras la muerte de Mao, muchos jóvenes que
habían sido enviados al campo regresaron
a las ciudades… y cómo no había trabajo,
se lo buscaron… por su cuenta. Y el gobierno
simplemente lo tuvo que aceptar… y así
de repente las tiendas privadas empezaron
a surgir como setas en las ciudades chinas,
terminando para siempre con el monopolio comercial
del estado.)
Y en cierto modo también ocurrió lo mismo
con las empresas municipales y regionales,
que empezaron a surgir fuera del control del
estado... gracias a lo cual durante años
fueron las más dinámicas de toda China..
Sí, es verdad, el gobierno de Deng Xiaoping
no frenó estos cambios, todo lo contrario,
los acabó asumiendo como política…
Pero, como veis, gran parte del cambio, lejos
de lo que se nos cuenta vino de abajo arriba….y
no de arriba abajo. Tal vez por eso… la
transformación de China ha sido tan grande
en tan poco tiempo.
[Por cierto, antes de que nos deis de palos,
Deng Xiaoping no fue ningún santo… fue
un dictador… como el resto de líderes chinos.
Sin ir más lejos la represión de Tiananmen
fue responsabilidad suya.]
Pero ahora turno para ti:
¿Crees que China terminará convirtiéndose
en una democracia?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta. Si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo dale a like y compartelo
con tus amigos.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.